[Music]
try to go back in time and imagine
yourself as a baby I'm not gonna ask you
to start crying or crawling around the
room but try to think of the major
learnings you had perhaps it was
learning how to walk or how to hold an
object by yourself maybe it was learning
how not to heat your baby friends or
even how to say her first words but let
me ask you by a show of hands how many
of you were taught how to see no one
right you shouldn't blame your parents
for that my point here is that human
sight is usually taken for granted
unless you lose it for some reason or
unless you're born with an eye
impairment which was my case too your
friendly eyes it might seem that I don't
have any problem but I was born blind
from my left eye and I have low vision
in my right one so I'd like to welcome
you to my world that's probably a very
good approximation of how I see things
in this case this is not a thing but
actually the love of my life on our
wedding day but the fact is that since I
was a kid I had to understand how to go
through that blur I had to learn how to
see now you might be asking what
learning how to see looks like what is
seeing well biology has an explanation
for us it says that it's all about light
light that goes through a series of very
delicate structures in our I like the
cornea
the pupil until it finally reaches our
retina a photosensitive tissue that
transforms light into electrical signals
those electrical signals then are
processed and travel from our eye to our
brain so in fact our eyes just collect
visual information but we see with our
brain according to science vision is an
activity 90% mental
and only 10% physical so when I look
back into my struggles I see now that
biology is indeed right and the act of
seeing is much more in here and maybe in
here than in here I truly believed that
real sight is based on three main actors
completely unrelated to our physical
condition and I hope to share them with
you today through some of the lessons
that I had in my life my first lesson
came pretty early at the age of four
trying to help me be part of the world
in a different way my parents decided to
put me in a music school and before even
learning how to read words by
transforming those little black
bloodstains into music notes I was able
to see a brand-new world through sound
but seeing that world required a lot of
effort a lot of practice and a lot of
dedication so I learned that seeing is
actually about the level of death you
put in everything you do in your life my
second lesson came some years later than
that I was 17 years old I was very shy
probably facing a lot of the same
challenges you've all faced at that age
but I had this crazy idea of auditioning
to a theatre company
well crazier than me were the ones who
accepted an actor who could barely see
to the other side of the stage but at
that same stage with a bunch of light in
my face
I learned that seeing is much more about
perspective by looking to the world
through the eyes of many many different
characters I learned how different
people are and yet how similar we are to
each other my third and final lesson
came more recently I've always been
passionate about photography
maybe because images were always a bit
mysterious and blurred to me I couldn't
see them well but I never thought I
would be able to use a professional
camera to take professional photographs
well recently I met a photographer and
he told me I have you ever noticed that
you only need one eye to look through
the viewfinder of a camera
indeed his right so this picture you're
seeing here was taken by a photographer
with just one eye you're looking at him
right now so through my photographs I
also learned that vision is much more
about focusing in your dreams focusing
in what matters most to you and why
I truly believe that all of those
lessons should be taught to us together
with that biology class I just showed
you some slides ago and I'm sure that
you all have already experienced at
least one moment in your lives where you
didn't use even those 10% to actually
see the world don't you remember that
very first case when you almost
automatically automatically close your
eyes I'm sure you're very very focused
at that moment how about the dozens of
times your friends asked you to close
your eyes just to hit you with a
surprise from a brand new perspective
not to mention watching a concert where
your favorite rock star closes his eyes
at the peak of the song I'm sure he was
seeing a lot of stuff in that moment and
experiencing the deepest emotions Helen
Keller was an American educator and
activist for the blind and the deaf
people she was blind actually and she
once said what I'm looking for is not
out there
it's in me so I'd like to invite you to
step into my world even if you have
perfect sight so the next time you face
a challenge a hard decision or even a
simple pleasuring life try not to look
at it only with your eyes wide open
close them and open up your brain so you
can unlock a different kind of vision
one that goes beyond that blur and helps
you be more focused broaden your
perspectives and look deeper inside
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]